got something very very very special for
you guys Greg Miller aunt
Shuhei Yoshida happy birthday saying
happy birthday happy birthday Tim hi
everybody how are you how are you
enjoying the show so far shot up to the
man in the wing wing' shirt keep it all
again between alive ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to the stage Shuhei
Yoshida grab see right thank you thank
you for coming shooting oh yeah you need
a microphone don't you
hello danga yeah you know that I was one
of the producers of the original crash
bandicoot game I cannot be excited me
now I had a chance to play crush 1 2 & 3
yam ps4 the other day and like they are
saying they made crush one a little bit
easier because it took too hard yeah you
know I struggled as a producer but every
level stop right there if you were
struggling as a producer yeah I won't
think about dialing down the difficulty
actually we did we did for the Japanese
version ok the US and European version
came out in September I remember but we
have three months we released the first
crush game in December in Japan yeah I
worked with mark sunny and Naughty Dog
guys to make it a little bit you know
easier for the Japanese version we're
happy to reunite you your former
employee over there Crash Bandicoot ah
let's start with the biggest PlayStation
story of III 2017 which was your in
everybody's golf yes as if I couldn't
love the Hot Shot / everybody got golf
more you put Shuhei in there I got to
play as you today it was fantastic thank
you thank you so I was at the booth and
I saw someone praying as me and I like
buddy good I go so how how is she doing
this
are they talking about it how did that
happen oh yeah so the this character was
made just using the same edit you know
character ID too that they have in game
yeah so you can create anyone and as a
developer made these two they wanted to
demonstrated how versatile it is
so they created me and Sean leading and
on drew house and all those bunch of
people just using the same to cash and
AH the PR person you know suggested oh
why don't we use just shoot a character
for the e3 demonstration that might
attract in the people's attention but
yeah haha is it shipping with you you're
gonna be in the game I could be yeah
I'll do what I'm in the game everybody's
going in the earlier version I saw me as
one of the galleries you know watching
you know people pray yeah you got it to
it I think I think for the people who
love everybody's golf if you're a
hotshots fan like me know Shuhei your
sheet it makes perfect sense
thank you so sure how how is how's it
been how is he three 2017 been for you
and boy it's been very relaxing yeah
nobody asking questions nothing half
like like you saw the show right yeah
they just so Layton came came came out
you know spoke form one minute yeah and
all the presentation was like in a video
game game game yeah yeah so there's no
like a technical issues that we don't
have to you know worry be worried about
yeah and there's no like are switching
people and so the we didn't have bahasa
yeah this just one run-through
I'll have the window night of the day
before night before the you know so
Jacuzzi we didn't do any different on
the same day so this we can hit play
pretty much right Walker yes however
however if you um yeah you are in the
auditorium right no I was watching from
home oh forget you notice they there's a
people coming down when there's a zombie
oh yeah precast yeah effort
and they move there are people yeah you
yeah you're hired real peanut angle yeah
yeah it is you're serious
so all those things that water came down
from the ceiling yeah he came the
display just so so amazing to be inside
you guys nail presentation last year
with the orchestra this year with again
more live music the water was amazing
yes so how did you feel about your games
liner um pretty good yeah how did you
feel about Playstations games line up
thank you thank you yeah so the if you
had noticed we had to put many of our
games coming out this year in the
pre-show over easily media circus
because we wanted to make the actual
show within one hour games like you know
Gran Turismo sport everybody's goal not
to and the order in a new play link yeah
as I said I already gave you yeah yeah
yeah all those things we have to show it
before the show started so if you have
not noticed we had another show one hour
show we aired live right before the e3
press you know a media showcase and it's
it's on our YouTube channel so please
watch there are lots of new information
about Avery goals and Gran Turismo and
the play link and all these games so
very interesting
no pearpod in there where was the you
where you know we're kind if it better
come quick all right yeah I just woke a
raucous out good for them now give the
people what they want they want Patapon
it's now playable from beginning to the
end you know awesome 4k graphics and the
team is making sure that you know so
it's now and in the final consultation
stages Japan studio because the original
creators they are still there to make
sure that you know game is people
resolve the original feel and look I'd
be very fact that you know if it wasn't
preserved if it came out it wasn't what
I want yeah you tell I would let you
know I got in the the golf game you know
that
these are like you talk about is my you
know decade in the industry yeah we're
literally reliving like the 2007 2000
PSP era that I like that I love so much
2007 2008 I'm stoked I'm talking about
everybody's golf did you notice that
this time around we have put the
developer was able to put nine holes
together again one now break up yeah
yeah so you can walk to or you know user
card to move to any poll you don't have
to follow the you know in sequence or I
didn't see that and I eat you know when
you start a game you are automatically
matched up with other players in playing
at the same time so you just see other
people wandering around while you are
playing the golf or you can watch other
people play you know online under you
you can crop or you can some you know
dancing sure yeah fraps other players I
expect you to be dancing for me when I'm
when I'm playing golf yeah yeah so it's
a very library in a golf game it's like
open world oh yeah I can't wait to do it
I can't wait to get hands out I get like
deep hands-on with me actually have it
at home yeah um so I think it's the only
criticism I've seen of the PlayStation
conference right was the fact that there
was a lot of games from last year
and a lot of didn't have like solid
release dates hmm
what is your what your a lot of them
were the worldwide studios games that
you're in charge of these people yeah
after the pyramid actually that was
really intentional yeah like grant
original spot coming for 2017 go to war
coming re 2018 because we had announced
release dates of many games that we had
to approach eyes and push back in the
past so we and got together and
discussed seriously because the ps4
games are so big and all the teams in a
very veteran teams making games for the
last 20 years still miss calculate how
much work is done at the very last part
of the development being in a polishing
or debugging so we agreed to not to
announce the release days until the
very very very close to the ladies day
so that puts a lot of challenge to our
marketing on the sales team sure but
they understood and agreed and allowed
us to just say the windows like a season
like a four or spring or early until the
we are so close to like a better finish
so that's the reason that we didn't
announce the actual date is that does
that make it a really tough decision on
what to show when like to you know to
show something like days gone last year
and show it again this year and not have
a day during like that and which is fine
Eric Jensen working his butt off I
understand but I mean is that like it
feels like you guys have had to change
strategy I guess um what so we have you
know portfolios games you know we're in
development and we share that with our
marketing on the PR teams and and every
game has a certain point in development
that's optimal to show and announce and
you know because we have many events in
the year so we have to do and oh yeah
strategize like to place where to put
you know what content source yeah so
where are you strategizing to play
sucker-punches game cuz I'm sick and not
seeing it I think it was two years ago
on this stage you told me you would
played it and I still don't see anything
about it i I think I have prayed many
many more times
hahaha God Oh such game and every time I
pray I I you shouldn't be talking
okay I can expect that so it's it's a
game it is a game yeah come on she's
making a game they are not making movies
or in thank you good we start knocking
it out it's like guess who now we're
just not even now they're not all
exactly exactly right on top of that
right um what how many III see bad new
shoe I remember us they are the very
first one when the Steve race came out
and just said 299 yeah as in the to
announce the price of original
PlayStation that those
huge so so I think that was a very fast
III so i mean ii III every every year
yeah what do you think of this year
being open to the public
that's a lots of energy like I feel a
little bit like PSX you are there yeah
so III think I like it in terms of the
atmosphere and energy but it's gonna be
much more challenging for like a media
people to play games and we have a media
room so in a hop read they have have
enough time to get their hands on share
the games but I hope people are enjoying
are you enjoying me 83 yeah they're
doing all right don't worry about that I
have a fine time so for you right now
what's it like to have so many games
coming that people are super excited for
but then still be able to come out and
now something like shout out the classes
yeah how long has that been in
development how long have a there was no
I had no idea that was coming yeah so
this is a completely make of the game
every asset everything is you know made
new for changing the control scheme with
doing some tweaks okay yeah I can live
that I don't that because it's been a
long time since a very original game and
they have certain things that people
like I expect in terms rag like
interface yeah so we develop a group
point and Japan studio experimenting
with something I'm not allowed to talk
about details but the eye as you know
blue point made the ps3 HD version of
shadow of the crosses and eco so they
know the game inside out yeah and there
are people in Japan city of who worked
on original as well so they are really
making the game preserving the original
game the feel and gameplay however to
really be creating the game with the
contemporary current gen ps4 graphics
and the
engines so for people who have no idea
about this game our goal is to make this
game look like any other new ps4 sharing
a brand new game or title that's why we
didn't put LeMay core anything in the
title we just call it shadow of the
colossus I feel I would be wrong so
sorry so to answer your question so
ladies peak overshoot if they've been
spending quite a long time yeah as you
could tell yeah yeah making this game
yeah yeah it was going on in parallel
with the Last Guardian development you
know yeah
so they've definitely been working on it
for quite a while I feel this is a
golden opportunity to catch up with you
yeah we get to talk quite a bit but not
as often as I'd like anytime you want to
leave Sony behind come work for kind of
funny let me know oh yeah so I can take
the coning so we'll bring back peace I
love you xoxo if you want to co ah we
can get the under golfer back yeah I am
Crimmins about sure we have you fitted
money the Patriots are doing really not
as well as you think
no my question for you would be talk to
me a little bit about PlayStation VR I
was so thrilled to see PlayStation VR up
during the conference you guys had the
five games that I predicted good job and
thank you for doing the live stream of
moss I watched it
oh yeah play through and do watching the
game being played by a person yeah under
C's actual game on screen and the pass
on pre injure that really is a good way
to communicate what theory is the
experience of playing the game you know
I mean like our audience loves
PlayStation VR and they want to see more
and more stuff about it so we're happy
to get out there but like for you we
talked so much leading up to it how have
you felt post-launch for about
PlayStation VR yeah so the well from in
terms of number of units you know we
couldn't keep up with you know producing
that so you know because going in
because it was a very fast year the
consumer level high quality we are has
been possible it was very difficult to
read the extra demand you know the $399
is not cheap at all so it's an expensive
system because we want to make sure the
experiences amazing when we come out
because
via takes people's senses away and put
them into different world so we really
really really needed to put a very high
quality advanced tech component that
which we did yeah so there are
challenges in terms of producing we need
to catch up with the demand but now you
go to the stores you should be able to
find the salsa we be holding back our
marketing and sales teams has been
holding up by promoting the system
because we didn't have you know enough
minutes but going forward because we
have enough minutes we are planning on
moving into the littles
we will start promoting the system and
games coming up that's all I want to
hear and that's why if we was such a
positive move for because it was the
fear right oh we got launched and then
got quiet and it was is it doing well
it's owning it is so supported or
they're gonna make games for it
you guys still are yeah that the reason
as I said was because of the you know
retail inventory situation oh great
lacy job over this issue hey Ishita
Thank You chef Thank You ma ba da get up
here
yeah thank you for coming by all right
now get off the stage